hi this is vi and i'm here with buzzfeed
to read your thirst twits pretty nervous
to read your thirst twist but just
another title
let's dive in
[Music]
okay the first one people might be
thirsting over you but i just want you
to meet my parents
later i'm thirsty for you but i will try
this the kind way can we just cuddle
forever and i will protect you from all
the snakes not only on the han riverfest
but in the world love you always i love
you always too
i'm being have you been to the hospital
to the health checkup lately because you
seem like
like a vitamin
[Music]
but we can make love anywhere oh i mean
just literally love not like
we can make love everywhere
the epitome of beautiful lovely handsome
stunning excellent perfect exquisite
gorgeous extraordinary
fundamental
attractive pretty charming flawless
magnificent divine elegance astonishing
godly
mess
okay i got your point but
it was really hard to read hanbin is so
fine i sometimes look at him and want to
start
barking not gonna lie barking
why not we are of the same age but it's
always a dilemma whether i should call
you baby or daddy in my opinion
baby is better are your biceps and
necklace they fit around
[Music]
because i want to ride you all night
long this is my first time to read those
kind of twists this this kind of
commence so i don't know how to say
i'm not a sports car but
i'm being
your body is so hot
but
it will look even harder with it on top
of me
i understand it but
i'm speechless
aka bi i can help you make music by
making you rich high notes
[Music]
[Music]
maybe not only one place if you were in
the same
bed with han bin we would probably
make it go
around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can i see it on your face
now i'm curious how to reaction other
people human being is so hot speaking in
english um suddenly 9 months
[Music]
please continue going down in history
while i go down on you hanbini
[Music]
no matter what i'm gonna i'm gonna
continue like my history han bin
i hope you know i can become
i'm a waterfall traditional waterfall
i'm still speechless dear i'm being i'll
let you feel my whole world let's start
[Music]
then i'll let you feel my
word
let's start with my old first oh
oh i'm getting hot since you don't like
driving what about riding
you can start with my face other id said
you wanna sit on my face and she wanna i
don't know he or she but she she said
she want me to
write her face i don't want to imagine
anything
destroy my esophagus very
creative
[Music]
on
[Music]
the seed in me you can do the harvest
together after 9 months
[Music]
[Music]
cowgirl
doggy missionary cowgirl reverse cowgirl
upside down
inside out one leg up
two legs off in public
on a spaceship
in the garden
on the grass in the car
i'm not i can understand what you're
saying in public
in public
[Music]
if i see another
lucky person get a selfie with hanbin
i'm just going to hold my breath and
try to die
thank you buzzfeed be sure to check out
btbt in public
[Music]